HAOHSIANG LIAO: American
people, they usually
have the myth that Chinese
is a very difficult language
to master which is true if
you want to learn the four
skills altogether.
We are talking about listening,
speaking, reading, and writing.
Chinese is difficult in the
sense of Chinese characters.
If you focus on just
listening and speaking,
the structure of
Chinese language
is the same as English.
It's SVO language.
So you say, I like you.
As long as you know how do
you say, I, like, and you
individually, and you put
together, it's, I like you.
So it's not Japanese.
Japanese is SOV.
So you have to say, I
you like in Japanese.
So again, if you
just want to focus
on listening and
speaking, Chinese
is not so difficult to master.
Most of the Chinese textbooks,
they combine these four skills
altogether.
So a dialogue would
be represented
in Chinese characters.
And reading Chinese characters
is a big burden for beginners.
And our curriculum here is our
speaking and listening class,
they have different units.
And that is one
of the reasons we
would like to adopt these
new materials at MIT.
And the material is called
Basic Spoken Chinese
and Basic Written Chinese.
So the idea is it
separates the speaking
and listening from the
reading and writing.
So for the first two
weeks, our curriculum
here is that we focus on
the speaking and listening.
So students, they get
a solid foundation
of what Chinese sounds like.
After two weeks, then we
slowly introduce the reading
and the writing part.
And our pace here is our
speaking and listening classes,
they're always one week ahead
of the reading and writing.
There are some good
purposes for doing that.
One of them is reading and
writing will become review
for the speaking and listening.
So when students
read, the materials
is something you already know
from speaking and listening.
So their energy, their efforts,
can be put entirely focused
on decoding the characters.
So they don't need to go
through the process of,
so what is meant by this
word and by that word
because they already
learned this in the speaking
and listening class.